nearly 50 years ago yon winter
co-founded a small little music
publication in San Francisco the
rock-and-roll newspaper was called
Rolling Stone he printed the first
edition with $7,500 that he raised from
friends winner was just 21 years old at
the time
Wow he wrote this in the editor's note
we hope that we have something here for
the artists and the industry and every
person who believes in the magic that
can set you free that hope translated
into success Rolling Stone has now
published more than 1200 issues it
covers and shapes
music politics and pop culture two of
his best-known writers Tom Wolfe and
Hunter Thompson spoke with CBS in 1987
about what makes Rolling Stone so
special Rolling Stone has been extremely
flexible and willing to take chances
and not frightened with Rolling Stone I
was given the the room in the range to
really get us you know to stomp on the
terror at Lord Buckley said and very few
places uh will you get it the magazine
is celebrating its golden anniversary
with the new book 50 years of Rolling
Stone teachers an introduction by
co-founder Yann winter and he joins us
now good morning good morning way back
50 years ago in San Francisco what the
hell did you think you were doing I
didn't know I mean I was a kind of wild
rock and roll kid I love music and want
to do something about that but I had no
idea of what it would help them become
have become such a big mainstream
publication located in New York and
talking to presidents and going to Oval
Office and of course one and doing all
that and buttoned up did rock and roll
to its it well dog all stems from rock
and roll as I said in the beginning I
think that when we started to cover
music in the beginning young we had the
Beatles and stones and Dylan they were
beginning to form a have a worldview and
a conscious and an attitude you know and
it reflected that kind of the concerns
of the just coming-of-age baby boom you
know which is kind of new idea about
politics and since I was a Lea native
from then that then Society and it had a
kind of social mission at its core even
then and people didn't see that by the
way we
did see that we celebrated you must have
been a different kind of kid though we
on because you were 21 years old I
marvel at that when you look at the 21
year olds today now I can remember it I
was like a 21 just the fact that you
could think that at 21 you said you
wanted to give rock-and-roll a voice
what was the story for that voice then
you didn't think that you thought was
missing well at that time the
publication's a few publication covered
music were really keen age you know fan
magazines it was like little teenage
girls it was viewed as that kind of
thing and there was no coverage of rock
and roll in the New York Times or the
magazines or on television or anywhere
and really it was just kind of you could
get rocking on top 40 radio in the
jukeboxes and we wanted to say something
about it and you could get it in Rolling
Stone then we sort of became a voice of
it you know and let the groups and the
artists talk through us and explain
themselves to their audience through us
I mean it was it was a newspaper at
first on a rotary press that you guys
the first time we watched it and clicked
your champagne glasses watching you come
up and now it's the magazine in that
first year too when you had interviews
with Mick Jagger and Pete Townsend how
did you get those interviews well I
think they saw what we were doing as
small as it was and in San Francisco
which is way off the beaten track then
they saw what was they liked it makes us
realize that we were taking them kind of
on their own terms and you know
infecting their transience with which
they took their music you know and not
just you know what color if they letter
what they weren't looking for in a
girlfriend like that and they respond
sense get something and they receive
they respond to us they wanted to talk
about it you know they knew that they
were going to get things what else you
did as you found the great Hunter
Thompson writing a great any Leibovitz
right and then you said about Hunter I
could never find another hunt well you
just you know bits it's a one-of-a-kind
yeah there's certain you know between
his skill as a writer and a reporter and
it's you know really colorfully he was
also a amazing personality you had on
many times I mean it's just loved being
with Hunter was you knew you were going
to just have the most kind of exciting
time of your life you know with them
something you're always going to live on
the edge of danger you know just being
with you know a car with in those days
yes and Annie Leibowitz back to
Charlie's thing about Annie Lee woods
because you wanted that magazine that
paper to have a look we leave the
photography I believe an essential part
of
raka was the look of it in the style of
it and the image of it and so I wanted
photography in there good photography
now Annie just wanted her office on her
own she was a student at San Francisco
Art Institute and gave you some pictures
she took and we started giving her
assignments and she kept coming back
better and better and better and soon
enough I mean I had no idea when I saw
her the first time that you'd end up
being the world's one of the world's
greatest looking photographers or
picture of John Lennon and Yoko Ono
that's your your favorite picture well
it's not my favorite picture but
certainly the most astounding cover ever
just the image itself is so powerful and
then it was published at time when she
was killed and so it became connects
trickable part of what happened and that
image speaks without a scale again
really profound though change 50 years
concludes highs and lows yeah where do
you put the University of the gin well
it pour tea that's a low I mean we made
a really big mistake that I mean the
underlying story and reporting was all
Acuras important issue rape on campus
that know nothing of what we said about
title 9 enforcement has ever been
discredited we were right about it
unfortunately the example we use turned
out to be not true and on that mistake
we got hung yeah that's the thing you
you know we've been doing this did a big
damage in terms of you and the readers
know it just was a you know upsetting
incident but that you know you for 50 if
you do 50 years of this kind of
reporting and daring and yeah and it
happened so quickly to you is the once
at once-in-a-lifetime thing it happens
as to other people's having the times
now your son is going to be taking over
is the word that's the word how do you
feel about that what does he bring that
you don't
well youth energy all the things I was
brought to it myself young you still
have that can I just tell one quick
story about beyond winter yeah I first
came to New York he had a little party
at his office I went over there and I
saw this table and I love this table
and I knew it would be a centerpiece for
the show that I was going to do and so I
went to him and I said can i buy that
table not is it okay with my desk and he
said me no no he said to me check into
it you call me back and I can't do this
because it was at the original San
Francisco dead but what he did is he
found me
and help me find the table that has been
at the centerpiece of my show more than
25 years did that yeah yeah Charlie
since it's that clear table the original
because of you like yeah
eunbong are many accomplishments I don't
looking at your pictures younger I mean
look at you that I look at your face and
what you were thinking you were such a
kid I was but you started a graduations
I'm 50 thank you very much
Thank You Nora gale pleasure to be here
celebrate 50 years of Rolling Stone is
on sale now you bet it's a little book
nor oh it's a good book I'm getting the
guy